well let's now bring in maliksal he's a
supreme court lawyer and he joins us
also from Islamabad Malik I want to take
a step back here and understand the
plethora of charges that Imran Khan is
facing they include what corruption
terrorism and the use of illegal funds
how many warrants are we talking about
some of these are really quite serious
charges
interestingly there are more than 75
fires registered against him and in
blochistan the high court has interfered
and has crashed most of the fias
but the fact is that there are so many
cases that actually nobody knows how
many cases are there and the police is
coming up with warrants off and on and
so many variants are in the field that
is really very confusing but right now
what we have seen is that the high court
has stopped the operation of the police
and has directed The Imran Khan has
given an undertaking to appear in the
court so right now we just heard that
there is an order from the Islamabad
high court that repetition which had
challenged the warrants have been
dismissed so the natural course would be
that Imran Khan has to appear in the
court on 18th until then I think there
is no
there's no such protective order as yet
because the operation has been stopped
but no protective order has been given
yet so what really clearly his
supporters feel that there's a lot at
stake here Imran Khan I believe could be
banned from politics if he's found
guilty in any of these cases obviously
he's hugely popular
actually the fact is that everybody
knows that all these cases they are just
political victimization there's nothing
in the in those cases and in Pakistan it
has become a kind of a very normal
course that when whoever comes into the
park they just drag the other person
into the litigation and the criminal
prosecution and nobody gets the results
it has been going on for last so many
years and the people are fed up of this
and now people don't trust about these
cases and everybody knows that these are
just false Acquisitions so what my point
is that
you see in Pakistan you don't get
conviction but actually the rigors of
the child or the rigors of the dragging
that is really what what really is the
punishment so it's uh I think it's more
than a retractable victimization which
is going on but right now
Imran khanon has the only option and
that option is that he has to appear in
the code and if in Islamabad he gets a
protective order sure probably that will
save it Malika I do want to ask you you
say this is politically motivated Imran
Khan says this is politically motivated
you yourself are a supreme court lawyer
just how independent are the courts
you see this is a very interesting
question in Pakistan it's a some kind of
a complex Judicial System the lower
courts working they are directly under
the control of the executives so there's
not much Independence in them but as you
go through the higher Iraqi like high
potential Supreme Court they are working
independently but the procedure is such
and they say all the colonial laws that
they these laws actually don't give you
much margin to have a I would say a fair
Trend in Pakistan because the power
which are with the executive they are so
so much powerful that they can do
anything just like even yesterday
you can change the judge in just two
hours like yesterday they changed the
judge who had given him a little bit of
relief so executive actually controls
the Judiciary in one way or the other
it's only this period Judiciary but the
spirit Judiciary sometimes feels very
handicapped because of the laws because
of the system which actually controls
the jurisdiction of the Supreme Court
saver so Malik clearly a very volatile
situation there still Malik after their
supreme court lawyer speaking to us from
Islamabad thank you for sharing your
thoughts with us on Al Jazeera sir
thank you very much thank you